avec nous ce soir stéfane marion
économiste et stratège en chef à la
banque nationale stéfane marion bonsoir
soir 4 dollars le baril pour le wcs puis
on va voir le graphique depuis le début
de l'année on est à 38 dollars en début
d'année pour on a touché 3 dollars 81 2
aujourd'hui comment ça s'explique en
fait monsieur fillon je vois pas votre
graphique mais je sais pas mais j'ai
vérifié aujourd'hui peu un gros
cappuccino j'étais morton se transigeait
à 4,95 donc ça vous donne une geek ou
pas vraiment d'un prix de baril de
pétrole
totalement déprimé qui reflète la guerre
de prix mais aussi une baisse
spectaculaire de la demande mondiale de
pétrole qui reflète la fermeture de
plusieurs économies mais aussi le
confinement au niveau des ménages qui
empêche les gens de voyage y donc c'est
un peu spécial qu'on assiste à une
guerre de prix dans un contexte où la
demande s'écrase devrait y avoir des
mesures moment donné pour colmater le
cette baisse de prix je pense je pense
j'ose espérer qu'un accord entre les
gros producteurs 1 d'ici quelques temps
mais entre temps l'effet est dévastateur
pour l'industrie pétrolière au canada
comme à l'industrie peut survivre à ce
prix généralement parlant autant de prix
du pétrole qui en deçà de 25 dollars
américains le wti la peau poils du
blessé s les compagnies arrivent son kif
kif au niveau de faire un profit
évidemment avec un prix du pétrole wti à
20 dollars qui se traduit par wcs en
deçà de 5 $ qu'on fait pas d'argent et
on met en péril aussi l'industrie
canadienne
et ça c'est très important monsieur
fillon veut pas à ce que l'économie
mondiale ferme pour quelques semaines
assistez à une destruction permanente
d'un secteur aussi stratégique au canada
et stratégique aussi pour l'économie du
québec parce que quand même 40% du
pétrole brut consommé au québec provient
du reste du canada
alors comment le gouvernement peut aider
l'industrie est ce qu'ottawa va aider
l'industrie pétrolière est ce que c'est
clair pour vous je pense que c'est clair
que comme on ne peut pas ignorer
l'industrie du transport aérien on ne
peut pas ignorer une industrie qui
représente dans une économie comme
l'alberta près de 25% de son cohésion
d'économie peut-être quatre à cinq pour
cent des travailleurs au niveau
pancanadien
c'est trop groupe pour ignorer je pense
qu'il y aura des efforts faits en ce
sens pour aider le secteur énergétique
jusqu'au moment où la demande mondiale
de pétrole reprennent et ça pourrait
ressembler à quoi ce soutien écoutez on
doit innover
on doit tenir compte des compagnies qui
ont les reins assez solides pour les
prochaines semaines il y aura peut-être
des prises de participation du
gouvernement dans certaines entreprises
on ne peut rien exclure au moment actuel
le monsieur fillon
donc comme on a fait avec franz anton je
crois que oui en fait on peut pas je
crois que oui je pense que c'est une des
options sur la table
or on voit qu aux etats unis le
gouvernement prend des participations au
niveau des entreprises pour convaincre
aussi les payeurs de taxes que ce ne
sera pas de l'argent nessma qui vont
bénéficier si on met de l'argent lors
paiement des baux en jeu qui pourrait
avoir un retour sur le west main un peu
comme l'a fait pour l'industrie
automobile 2009 16h on devient
actionnaire sais c'est pas une
subvention c'est plus un actionnariat
dans l'objectif de le revendre comme
c'est le cas pour le projet trans
mountain l'objectif c'est de le revendre
éventuellement il manque donc amplement
rien exclure sa retraite un mélange
subventions des prises de participation
l'actionnariat
je pense que toutes ces choses là sont
sur la table pour les prochains jours se
dit à des entreprises qui abandonnent
déjà leur investissement capital cc
c'est difficile de trouver de la
rentabilité dans des projets qui sont
exigeants les projets de sables
bitumineux est ce qu'on peut penser que
beaucoup de projets d'investissement
capital qui seront abandonnés
absolument je pense que même en deçà de
40 dollars plusieurs projets
d'investissements déjà été abandonné
vous savez le coût marginal pour faire
de l'argent sur un nouveau projet ou au
canada et bien au delà de 50 dollars le
baril de pétrole wti donc à 20 dollars
que nous sommes
aujourd'hui il ya tout projet
d'investissement qui auront lieu au
canada pour les prochaines années donc
les prévisions de croissance qui avaient
fait pour la production de pétrole au
canada devront vraisemblablement être
revues à la baisse
un mot sur la subvention salariale à
toutes les entreprises annoncées par le
premier ministre trudeau peu importe le
nombre d'employés vous en pensez quoi de
ce monsieur me marion mais je pense une
excellente eut dit vous savez dans un
contexte où on était en plein emploi il
ya à peine quelques semaines et dans un
contexte on sent enfermé l'économie pour
quelques semaines
ce serait dommage qu'on assiste à une
séparation permanente entre les
employeurs et les employés dans un
contexte on détruit la capacité encore
une fois d'une volonté de réouvrir
l'économie au cours des prochaines
semaines
moi je pense que c'est bienvenu parce
que sans ce programme vous l'avez
mentionné tout à l'heure les deux
nouvelles demandes de son chômage nous
amener vers une direction le taux de
chômage allait atteindre plus de 16%
déjà au mois d'avril donc ce programme
là pour permettre de garder le lien
entre l'employeur et l'employé pour
faciliter la réintégration marché du
travail d'ici les prochaines semaines
donc je pense que c'est bienvenu ça
devrait coûter autour de 25 milliards
par mois
mais si le s'il implique ont payé pour
ne pas faire une cassure entre l'employé
et l'employeur je pense que si bien et
est il clair pour vous que l'économie
est fermée entre entre guillemets
jusqu'au 30 avril comme l'a indiqué dans
nos 30
j'ai pas de samba asie les anticipations
sur monsieur 30 mai ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'au niveau du développement de la
contagion dans certains pays il semble y
avoir une lueur d'espoir moi je pense en
fait si la prévision que j'ai soumis une
réouverture ou début mai mais évidemment
je suis quand même tributaire de tout le
scénario de contagion au niveau du col
de 19
je ne suis pas médecin mais force est de
constater que dans plusieurs pays
asiatiques
il semble y avoir une amélioration
tangible à ce niveau stéfane marion
merci pour cette analyse ce soir merci